[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we've been talking quite a
bit over the last few months over this
question of whether a sitting president
can be indicted and the reason that this
is a relevant question is because of our
current president we know that our
current president directed his attorney
Michael Cohen to commit multiple
felonies Michael Cohen by the way being
sentenced right now as we are recording
the show we'll have news about that for
you tomorrow we are still waiting to
find out what degree of a legal
coordination with a foreign power took
place during the 2016 election we're
waiting to figure out what is Robert
Muller aware of when it comes to
obstruction of justice and witness
tampering so we may at some point go
from the theoretical to the practical in
having to figure out can a sitting
president be indicted or would a sitting
president have to be impeached first
before indictments could follow if
indeed that president wasn't pardoned
preemptively this is all in the realm of
opinion right there is no law which says
you can indict a sitting president there
is no constitutional provision which
would prevent the indictment of a
sitting president it's not been tested
whether you can indict a sitting
president but we've heard lots of
serious legal opinions over the last six
months would say you wouldn't be able to
do it we have now a contrasting opinion
which I'm going to present to you today
and it's from Lawrence tribe who's a
legal scholar and a professor at Harvard
Law School here in the Boston area
who simply disagrees with the assessment
that you can indict a sitting president
he says oh yeah a sitting president can
be prosecuted no problem and in fact
it's part of how the framers of the
Constitution wanted a president who is
not immune
from consequences if they do the wrong
thing tribe wrote an op-ed piece in The
Boston Globe this week where he simply
says okay the Justice Department might
have a sort of de facto policy where
they would not indict a sitting
president but such a policy tribe argues
would be unconstitutional and tribe
actually points out specifically that
the strategy predicted by conservative
columnist Jennifer Rubin earlier this
week is likely to be exactly why
indictment of a sitting president as
possible Rubin suggested and we did this
clip for you earlier in the week that
Donald Trump would resign ten minutes
before the next Democratic president
would be inaugurated that could be in
2021 that could be in 2025 so that Mike
Pence would be president for those last
10 minutes of Trump's term and would
issue a pre-emptive pardon making it so
that donald trump could not be indicted
after he leaves the White House
we know that the framers of the
Constitution took very seriously that we
shouldn't have a king in the United
States and that there have to be ways to
deal with a potentially corrupt or
criminal person becoming president of
the United States so thus leaving
presidents free to sort of cash in these
get-out-of-jail-free cards with
pre-emptive resignation and pardoning by
their vice presidents who could be just
as corrupt as they are we don't know yet
when it comes to Mike Pence but the Vice
President could be just as corrupt as
the president it seems unimaginable as
what the framers would want that they
would want such a system where a
president can effectively make
themselves not vulnerable to any
consequences to their actions the point
that tribe makes in the op-ed which I
encourage you to read yourself is that
no matter what your view is on why you
can't indict a sitting president that it
would be unconstitutional if the Justice
Department has a policy that says we
don't indict sitting presidents tribe
argues that would be unconstitutional it
definitely doesn't seem that such a
formal policy exists but what if the
president
can always preemptively have themselves
pardoned by the VP that also would be
unconstitutional if indeed there is no
other way to make or or to subject a
president to consequences tribe argues
still for now this is in the realm of
the theoretical but it's getting closer
and closer to becoming a real issue
rather than merely a theoretical one
closer than it's been in a very long
time in American history and meat we may
well see it tested in the coming years
the entire perspective of Lawrence tribe
and those who by the way when I've
mentioned that the the wealth the
overwhelming majority of legal opinions
I've read say you can't indict a sitting
president people write to me and they
say no David that that's not accurate
their view is effectively we have a
president and not a king any system
which truly puts the president
off-limits from consequences is what we
would see in a theocracy or a
dictatorship not the type of government
that the framers established the problem
with this entire argument Pat is that it
does sort of depend on constitutional
interpretation and inferring what the
framers had in mind
that's a minefield when it comes to
something this serious well I certainly
hope that if this is litigated they
would find that you can indeed indict a
sitting president and I'm not just
saying that because Trump is president
or because the Republicans president I
just buy into this idea that no person
should be above the law and that
includes the president and how bad would
it be for the country if this goes to
the Supreme Court and they vote
completely on party lines like all five
conservative justices say that you can't
indict a sitting president and the four
liberals say that you can I think
they'll be really bad for the country
once again for everybody who said
Supreme Court doesn't matter Trump
versus Hillary doesn't matter it's all
basically going to be the same
yeah we're quickly seeing that that's
not the case one last thing on this I
got a question in the email from a
viewer who said if Trump can be indicted
and is indicted and goes to prison but
the Senate still controlled by
Republicans won't vote to remove him
after the house files articles of
impeachment could we have a president
running the country
from prison in theory you could
realistically you would think that the
cabinet would determine okay the
president can't carry out their duties
from prison and that the cabinet would
use the 25th amendment to remove Trump
in that case would Betsy DeVos actually
cast that vote though in that case I
hope so although I don't really know I
think you are really going to like this
one I was watching the videos I'm about
to play for you today
like the Zapruder film of john f
kennedy's assassination looking at the
insanity on an almost frame-by-frame
level here's what happened yesterday did
this is just this is the best donald
trump decided to invite the leaders of
the Democratic Party as of right now
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer in the
House and Senate respectively to the
White House to chat including about the
border wall with Mexico Mike Pence the
vice president was also there they
brought in cameras Trump started running
his mouth and Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer put Trump in his place in a way
that is not only glorious but
cringe-worthy in terms of Donald Trump
and Mike Pence's presence there and it
is just a pleasure to watch it's a
pleasure to listen to and we're gonna do
exactly that but before we get into the
video
what made Donald Trump think that this
was a good idea I I can't say maybe he
was overestimating his ability to think
on his feet and appeared to know a damn
thing but it went so bad for him first
Donald Trump starts telling Nancy Pelosi
that he has the votes in the house to
just build the wall on the Mexican
border of course he doesn't
and when Pelosi points it out Trump
weirdly seems to say no I I have the
votes but I have the Republican votes
but of course that ignores that you need
Democrats as well it just makes no sense
pay attention in this first clip to how
Donald Trump interrupts and just talks
over a Nancy Pelosi and I know I don't
say this because I'm quote triggered by
Donald Trump quote mansplaining or
anything like that I'm just pointing out
the brazen nature of how Trump is so
sure in what he's saying despite the
fact that it's totally wrong take a look
if I needed the votes for the wall in
the house I would have them in one
session would be done
it doesn't help because we need ten
Democrats and we're doing this in a very
friendly manner
it doesn't help for me to take a vote in
the house where I will win easily with
the Republicans it doesn't help to take
that vote because I'm not gonna get the
vote of the Senate I need ten senators
that's the problem and the house would
give me the vote if I wanted it but I
can't because I need ten votes from we
need border Security's first simple we
need border security people are pouring
into our country including terrorists
it's not clear whether the disconnect is
mathematical for trump or conceptual or
ideological but he just seems not to get
it so anyway this throws Trump into a
tizzy that at one point he says he
understands that Nancy Pelosi is in a
weak negotiating position which he
points out no she's not and please don't
characterize my position in this
discussion and then Trump goes so
haywire that he says he would gladly
shut down the government
Trump who constantly has preemptively
said that if government gets shut down
even if Republicans control everything
it would still be the fault of Democrats
Trump who slammed Obama for the
government shutdown that Republicans
caused during Obama's presidency now for
some reason says he would gladly shut
down government if he doesn't get what
he wants the effect of the the the it's
tantamount to saying I'm gonna take my
ball and go home and then he gets into
it with Chuck Schumer and it goes just
as poorly as when he was arguing with
Nancy Pelosi you say you want to put
that I said I'll take it okay good you
know what I'll say yes if we don't get
what we want one way or the other
whether it's through you through a
military through anything you want to
call I will shut down the gun okay
fair enough and is round and I disagree
I am proud to shut down the government
for border security job because the
people of this country don't want
criminals and people that have lots of
problems and drugs pouring into our
country so I will take the mantle I will
be the one to shut it down I'm not gonna
blame you for it
the last time you shut it down it didn't
work I will take the medal of shutting
down and I'm gonna shut it down for
border but we believe you this is just
the best I mean it there's a picture of
Pelosi and Schumer leaving the White
House and they just have these you know
what eating grins on their faces because
the guy just looks so stupid he will
never realize it he will never know it
some of his supporters may also think
that he appears strong here he thinks he
looks strong when he does it but he's in
over his head Pat and it becomes so
clear when he ends up talking himself
into a corner saying you know what I'll
gladly shut down government if you don't
give me everything I want and I won't
blame you I will take responsibility for
doing it just mistake after mistake and
looking like a fool it was pretty clear
that Nancy Pelosi got the better end of
Trump in their exchange and she was
certainly right but with Chuck Schumer I
don't know it's not so clear like I
think that that soundbite could really
come back to bite Trump if the
government does indeed shut down but
Chuck Schumer he's not engaging his
terrible posture he's hunched over like
I don't know if on an optics level of
that place so well for the Democrats
oh no you yes Chuck Schumer doesn't seem
to have great posture but he is having a
grand old time he set the trap Trump
walked directly into it and Trump is
just so mad that he's not getting his
way that he starts making absolutely
ludicrous threats he's saying if you
don't do what I want I'm gonna take my
ball and go home or I'm gonna pour oil
in the sandbox so that nobody can enjoy
it I will shut down the government and
the best thing about all of it if we can
put up the picture Pat possibly the best
thing is that Mike Pence is a mannequin
okay Mike Pence is not moving he shows
no signs of life during this entire
thing he apparently thought if I stay
completely still maybe people will
forget that I'm even in the room for
this stuff I mean just utterly amazing
down to the the most minut level I want
to hear from you about this what did you
think when you saw it I'm on Twitter at
the Pakman the show is on twitter at
david patten show the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com our program is mostly funded
by the audience people who listen to the
show people who watch the show and we
have this thing called membership which
you can sign up for a WWN pakman.com
today's newest member of the day is
Darren Gibson Darren signed up recently
and he's a great guy and I'm thrilled to
have Darren as a supporter of the show
also want to say thanks to someone who's
been supporting the show for much longer
Stephan view DES who has been following
the show for years and has been a member
for nearly five years the fond thank you
Darren thank you join them at WWN
pakman.com you can also make pledges if
membership seems too involved for you
which it shouldn't it's very simple but
if it does you can pledge as little as
$1 a month on patreon at patreon.com
slash david pakman show any amount you
want to pledge a dollar two dollars and
17 cents $1,000 a month as someone
pledges any amount is welcome
patreon.com slash david pakman show
let's get into this week's hatred mail
if you've never heard hatred mail before
it's when a professional
narrator professional voice-over artist
does interpretive readings of the hate
mail that I get here's a little more
information about hatred mail hey let's
face it the only logical response to
guns is more freaking guys
Patriot male written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom okay so this week's
hatred mail like many uses a lot of the
buzz words that are frequently parts of
hatred mail but it actually introduces a
term that I don't know if it could come
from some kind of faulty autocorrect of
my last name but it does make me room it
reminisce about my youth take a listen
to this and see if you can spot it great
blanket statement by a massively biased
propagator David Walkman being a
regressive like yourself is aligned with
men who are absurdly beta tragic stuff
David Pakman is clearly a beta Chuck
because he looks like he showers
regularly David you are so stupid you
don't even know that you are a socialist
yes so once again with the I'm actually
a socialist and don't even realize it
explain to me how I'm getting slammed by
those who say I should be a socialist
and by those who are saying I am a
socialist but when I saw instead of
David Parkman instead of whatever other
insults David Walkman
I actually am of an age where the
Walkman was phasing out as I was in my
youth this is completely foreign to you
right Pat I mean you have no idea what
these portable portable tape players are
I mean I know what it is because I've
seen old TV shows but that wasn't part
of my generation I grew up with iPods
yeah it was back when the world was
still in black and white that they still
uh they still use those make patriots
cry by using the coupon code hey tree at
forty when you get a membership at WWJ
in pokémon calm you go to that website
join pakman.com select the membership of
your choice when presented with the
option to enter a coupon code you tape
in hey tree at forty h80 our iot for
zero this saves you forty percent and it
sends a message to the hey tree it's
it's a middle finger really to the
hatred
that says you will not be intimidated by
their insults and you were supporting
the David Pakman show
thank you it brings me no comfort and
only disappointment to tell you today
that the United States is unfortunately
sadly becoming part of an alliance for
the bad and I will explain what I mean
back at a 2015 climate conference a
major study on the climate was
commissioned for the IPCC to undertake
they did this and the report came out
about six weeks ago or so and would it
sought to do was assess the impact on
our planet of a temperature increase of
one and a half degrees Celsius which the
report did but the report also pointed
out you know we've assessed the impact
of 1.5 C but we're actually heading
towards a 3 C 3 degree Celsius increase
of this century rather than the 1.5 that
we were initially asked to assess and
it's really really bad Poland is set to
host climate talk soon I mentioned that
to you in the last few weeks we now have
four countries for that object to the
Poland meeting welcoming this IPCC
report those four countries are Russia
Saudi Arabia Kuwait and the United
States so first of all yeah the common
theme there is oil Kuwait Russia Saudi
Arabia and the US all benefit from
plentiful harvesting of oil and use of
oil the top oil-producing countries are
on the same page when it comes to
prioritizing their oil production over
the planet not a big shocker in order to
stop the warming the world would have to
change its ways in terms of behaviors
that impact the climate but that would
also mean an impact on the oil
industries of these four countries Saudi
Arabia fought to limit the conclusions
of the report all four countries want
the report noted in Poland rather than
welcomed in Poland this is pure politics
right I mean that's what
it is but geopolitically we have no
choice but to contend with the reality
that the United States under Donald
Trump is increasingly part of this
science denying oil obsessed coalition
Obama did many bad things and I talked
about them when he was President of the
United States but do any of us believe
that the United States would be part of
this four country anti science coalition
if Barack Obama were still president
Hillary Clinton had endless flaws I
didn't vote for her in the Democratic
primary but can anybody honestly say
that she would have participated in an
objection to this climate report if she
was President of the United States this
is one of the issues of our time and
we're in a coalition that includes
Russia Saudi Arabia and Kuwait and no
other countries and I've said before Pat
you know you can judge people by the
company that they keep to a great degree
the United States pulls out of the Paris
climate agreement only country to do
that the United States protests an IPCC
climate change report and we're in
cahoots on that issue with Russia and
Saudi Arabia and Kuwait are we the bad
guys because more and more of the world
is seeing us that way yeah apparently so
we can only hope that the rest of the
world understands that Trump isn't the
best representative of the United States
and how most the people here think you
know if it is very hyperbolic of course
but let's say world war three breaks out
I don't know that we're gonna be on the
right side of things I don't know if
we're gonna be on the side of Canada and
France and England I think it would be
more likely that we would end up on the
side of Russia and Saudi Arabia well
that's exactly what I was sort of
thinking last night as I was reading up
on this story is it a good thing that we
are increasingly the ones standing with
Russia and Saudi Arabia on anything and
not with France and England and Canada
and so many of our traditional allies
this should horrify all Americans but
unfortunately there are trumpets who see
this in our emboldened by it they're
proud to be the
laughingstock of the world because they
see it as Trump not taking people's crap
it's getting worse on the climate issue
we're running out of time and we have
someone who's making the problem even
more acute and the situation even more
desperate make sure you're following me
on instagram david pakman also followed
the show on instagram at david pakman
show which is now featuring early
releases of Patriot mail rejected
voicemails that don't make it on for the
full show and a lot of other great stuff
at David Pakman show on Instagram follow
us the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it's great to be joined
today by dr. Hagee levine who is from
Hebrew University
Hadassah School of Public Health he's
also the lead author of a meta-analysis
into what is happening with sperm count
and male fertility
dr. Levine it's so great to talk to you
you know I've been reading more and more
about this issue and I think it's one
that a lot of people may not even know
is going on so let's introduce the
audience to what you've been studying
what trend are you seeing with in sperm
count and male fertility around the
world well if I may before I start I
actually start my presentation with the
famous statue of David and this is to
mention that we are interested in male
fertility not only of Kings for many
years however for some reason we totally
neglected male fertility now what's
important about the trend of sperm count
before we get to the results is that
sperm count is not only a great
indicator for male fertility
it's also influenced a lot by the
environment so we can learn from it
about the impact of the environment on
human health and more than that recent
studies have shown that sperm count and
semen quality is a predictor of
morbidity and mortality so if we have a
problem with sperm count it suggests
that we have problem with men's health
in general so against this background we
wanted to know what are the trends of
sperm counts around the world now 25
years ago there was a seminal paper by
Carlson and others which claimed that
there is a decline in sperm count at
least in Western countries however this
paper was received with a lot of
criticism and there was still a debate
so what we try to achieved is to
systematically review the literature we
screened over 7500 papers to get all the
papers with good data on sperm count and
to model the trends over time this is
called a meta-analysis and what were the
results that you found when doing this
meta-analysis so the results were
shocking no matter how we analyze the
data there was over 50 percent decline
in both sperm concentration and total
sperm count among men from Western
countries over the last 40 years imagine
any indicator human indicator that
declined by 50 percent in 40 years when
we modelled only studies after 1995 the
trend was even steeper and this is after
controlling for various factors such as
age and abstinence time so
if we you know if we summarize it
houston we have a problem we have a
problem with sperm count among men from
Western countries unfortunately we
simply don't have enough data to know
what are the current trends among men
from non-western countries yeah so one
question was going to be what do we know
about men from non-western countries
you've sort of preempted that by saying
we don't exactly know can you talk a
little bit about within Western
countries are there any other trends
whether they are demographic trends
whether they are particulars is it most
unnoticeable within any other subgroups
that you've looked at so I am a
scientist as a scientist I focus on the
facts and the fact is that in this study
our aim was to study the trends and I
cannot say based on this study what may
be the cause or what are the populations
or countries with the largest decline so
unfortunately this study at any study is
limited to answer the question is there
a decline or not and what is the
magnitude however for my studies and
from other people studies we can say
something about your question so we know
many of the problems that harm sperm
count and harm male fertility we know
that male reproductive health is
determined mainly in two periods in life
in the fetal period when the main
reproductive system is developing and
this time you need a very specific
cascade of hormones in order for the
testicles to develop properly and we
know that even one part per million one
drop in a swimming pool of an endocrine
disruptor could disrupt this development
and manifest later on in life as
low sperm count Oh as testicular cancer
or other problems of the male
reproductive system so we know that
exposure to chemicals such as phthalates
we know that exposure to stress we know
that maternal smoking all this could end
harm and testicular development and
could be some of the explanation for the
decline we see in sperm count which
means that when we look for the causes
we should not only look at the causes
over the last 40 years but we should go
maybe 78 years and look what happened in
the world and we know that during this
time there was obese attea demmick there
was massive exposure of the population
to new chemicals man-made chemicals that
we were never exposed before and some of
them were proven to disrupt development
of the hormonal system of the testicular
system on the harder on the other hand
also during adult life men produce sperm
by millions every day it's amazing there
is spermatogenesis process which takes
about 80 days so if an adult man like
you David is exposed to chemicals or to
smoking or is obese or is not physically
active it effect directly is
spermatogenesis and his semen quality
and we could also look for some of these
reasons and we know that men nowadays
are more more obese and much less
physically active so this could also be
part of the of the causes of the sperm
decline what I think we have to do we
have to acknowledge this is a major
public health problem on the global
level but also on the personal level
this is an opportunity for each one of
us to promote our own health which will
improve our health and improve our
fertility as well and we need to take
steps beside
doing much more wizards because we know
very little about men's reproductive
health we need to to take steps to
protect ourselves from chemicals from
smoking from obesity and and certain
foods and be more active so let's let's
see if we can explore a couple of the
ways in which this has consequences so
when it comes to human reproduction as
you mentioned we're talking about the
production of sperm cells by the
millions
you only need one in order to have a
baby so conceivably we could say that
the impact is not necessarily the
greatest when it comes to human
reproduction because there's a sort of
significant buffer built in because you
produce millions if you divide that by
two it's still millions you just need
one but it seems as though this issue is
connected to many other areas of health
for men is that true or do you believe
that I'm wrong that it is an issue for
human reproduction so you know as we say
you're both right and one so this is the
storm claim and the problem now it's
only the tip of the iceberg the problem
may continue if we don't understand what
are the causes
I'm not saying but other people saying
if you take the same graph by 2050 we'll
reach zero and so I don't want to
predict the future we don't know what
will happen in the future but even if
there is a chance of 1% that this
decline will continue and will you know
almost complete lack of sperm we
definitely need you know to do something
about it yeah at that point it will be a
problem for reproduction right also also
I know for my friends and maybe you and
our viewers know from their friends that
nowadays many couples have problem
conceiving they take them longer time
and many of them need assisted
reproduction now you know the animals
while they don't use assisted
reproduction we and we think we are you
know the best animal in the world we are
able to do the most basic function of
life to reproduce we need technology in
order to reproduce and the most common
factor when you study couples that have
problem conceiving the most common
problem is the main factor so I mean
it's 40% coding you know different
studies but 40% male factor 30% female
factor and 30% combined or unknown
factor so this is a huge problem
nowadays many men nowadays are
subfertile which is a bit under the
radar because we don't talk about it and
it's neglected we don't admit it and we
have technological solutions so the
problem is already now but besides that
my point that this is a very important
indicator it means that we have a
problem with our way of living that
seriously disrupt a major function and
if we don't understand what are the
causes and reverse them we will continue
to be insulted and this goes together
with increased in many different kinds
of cancer in specific congenital
malformations and in men cells in
general so as an indicator you know we
need to do something about it now also
about the first issue just to say when
you go before 40 million 4 ml studies
shows that you start to be subverted now
the mean got from 99 to 47 it means that
a huge proportion is below 40 so clearly
already now the percentage of men that
are sub fertile is definitely larger
than it used to be 50 years ago so we
need to do something about it because of
fertility issues because of health issue
and because it reflects a problem that
we need to acknowledge ok
the very limited time we have left I
would love to hear from you I know you
said we don't know what is causing it
but can you give us some sense of what
some of the studies are looking at in
other words are we talking about diet
are we talking about pharmaceuticals are
we talking about environmental factors
are we talking about all of these things
so first we looked at sperm count but
maybe also the sperm function is
hampered maybe one sperm that belong to
a population that is smaller that what
used to be before
maybe is also damaged in some way and we
do have studies answering your question
we do have studies on endocrine
disrupting chemicals which hints that
they not only empower and impair the
quantity but also the quality we see
epigenetic changes in the single sperm
so personally I am studying and I'm
worried about the impact of pesticides
and of phthalates and other man-made
chemicals on our fetal development
especially of the male and on our you
know on our bodies during adult life and
we are doing a mass experiment on human
population exposing them for the first
time to many many chemicals that
interact together and maybe some of them
are very harmful not only to ourselves
but also also to next generations and
the effects may be transgenerational so
personally I am very worried about
chemicals and I think we should do much
more not only in studying these
chemicals but also reversing the burden
of proof I think that before you
introduce a chemical to mass abuse and
exposure of the public it's your
obligation to show that is harmless
nowadays you can use any chemicals
exposed many people and unless you see
the bodies and have a clear proof that
it's harmful
there is no regulation so that's my main
world together with that I think that we
can do much better job in public health
in preventing obesity improving our diet
eating less processed food being more
physically active fighting tobacco and
smoking all of these factors that
clearly harm our personal and public
health and also made fertility we've
been speaking with dr. Hagee Levine he
is at Hebrew University's Hadassah
School of Public Health thank you so
much for talking to us about this issue
today thank you that is before the
pleasure the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
we could have had JD Schulten in Iowa's
fourth congressional district but
instead incumbent lunatic outrageous
ideological disgusting neo-nazi white
nationalist associated Republican Steve
King was able to retain his seat in a
narrow win that got us to yesterday when
the house had a hearing where they
questioned Google CEO sundar pichai the
idea I guess was to explore bias and
search result sort of but the questions
were mostly uninformed and based in
vague conspiracy theories about Google
manipulating search results and a total
lack of practical technology knowledge
by the members of the committee and at
one point during these hearings Steve
King who again is a totally clueless guy
tied to white nationalists but one of
the worst Republicans in the House of
Representatives he angrily demanded
answers from Google CEO about how an
iPhone works which of course is not made
by Google it's made by Apple which is
actually sort of a competitor to Google
at least on some platforms there is so
much going on in the clip I'm about to
play for you that I want to prepare you
for it so number one you'll notice that
when Steve King asks this question to
sundar pichai he actually hesitates for
a second sundar does you can see him
weighing the options and debating in his
own mind do I give some kind of
diplomatic answer about how iPhones work
or do I treat this guy like The [ __ ]
that he is and explain that Google just
simply doesn't make the iPhone watch for
that crucial moment where you can see
him running through the possibilities in
his head you're also going to notice
that in the background of the video
there's someone dressed like the
monopoly guy like from the board game
Monopoly that's Ian Madrigal who has
shown up before at hearings dressed as
uncle Pennybags from monopoly to call
attention to the lobbying money that
floats around Congress so all of that
and more is happening in this clip let's
take a look I have a seven-year-old
granddaughter who picked up her phone
before the election and she's playing a
little game kind of game a kid would
play and up on there pops a picture of
her grandfather
and I'm not gonna say into their record
what the kind of language was used
around that picture of her grandfather
but I'd ask you how does that show up on
a seven-year-olds iPhone who's playing a
kids game
congressman iPhone is made by a
different company and so you know I mean
it might have been an Android is just it
was a hand-me-down or some kinda you
know I guess I'm happy to follow up and
understand the specifics it there may be
an application which was being used
which had a notification but I'm happy
to understand it better and clarify it
for you okay thank you for your
testimony and yield back the balance of
my time
this is just just amazing and the
defenders are saying oh listen the
question could have applied to Android
or iPhone it's such a stupid question I
mean quite frankly it's such a stupid
question and so that's like the headline
goofy outrageous clip but there's
actually plenty of Democrats and
Republicans exposing how clueless they
are about how the internet works during
this hearing here's another one this is
congressman Lamar Smith a Republican
from Texas he asks Google's CEO to
confirm that Google has never punished
anybody for manipulating search results
and Google's CEO says no because no
individual person can do that take a
look number two also to my knowledge
you've never sanctioned any employee for
any type of for manipulating the
research results whatsoever is that the
case the time of the gentleman has
expired but mr. pitch I will be allowed
to answer question and very quickly it's
not possible for an individual employee
or groups of employee to manipulate our
search results you know we have a robust
framework including many steps in the
process well and my time is up let me
just say I disagree I think humans can
manipulate the process is a human
process at his face Thank You mr.
chairman yield back key recognize this
is just the best Lamar Smith disagrees
he knows nothing about anything but he
disagrees his feelings override the
facts he feels like individual employees
can mess with search results and he
wants them punished even though that's
not how it works now
of course I know in some broad sense
it's true right I mean humans made
Google so humans control how the
algorithm works but the idea that you'd
punish individuals for manipulating
search results is a bit silly and it
just shows how clueless Lamar Smith is
there are other clips if you want to see
more Steve King is a [ __ ] we know that
his constituents had a chance to vote
him out they opted to reelect him okay
the bigger picture from these hearings
is that it exposes that we have members
of Congress who don't know a thing about
technology in charge of figuring this
stuff out this is why instead of mostly
older lawyers and CEOs from industry we
need younger people we need people from
more diverse backgrounds scientists
people from more diverse professions
case in point we found out after
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham had
been on some tech committee maybe it was
cybersecurity don't remember exactly he
had been on this committee for a while
it was revealed that he had never sent
an email in his life Lindsey Graham 63
years old email has been around in some
forms since he was 17 years old
admittedly it wasn't ubiquitous back
then but it's been around and commonly
used since Lindsey Graham was in his mid
30s Pat why does he have to be on a
cybersecurity or tech committee if he's
never even sent an email like is this
really the best that we can do this is
the best that we have like he said most
of these people are lawyers and they've
been politicians for decades so they
don't understand tech and it's not to
say that they can't ask tough questions
I think they can and they can press
these CEOs and make sure that they get
to the bottom of things but they should
do less grandstanding and more listening
at the end of the day yeah I mean just
the the questions expose how little they
understand about how things work and I'm
reminded of that law someone at one
point in New York State got off on child
porn charges because of how the raw law
was written just viewing child porn is
is not possessing it because you didn't
like right click save as to your
computer and this allowed people at
least one person potentially more to get
out of child porn
just then they went in and changed the
law and it's this kind of reactive
situation we need on issues of
technology and cybersecurity we need our
elected officials to be proactive you
can't be proactive unless you have some
understanding of what the hell is going
on
however impressive it might be what
Baron Trump is doing with computers we
actually need our elected officials not
the children of presidents to be
knowledgeable informed and working for
us and proactively rather than seemingly
indifferent to how the real world
actually operates when it comes to these
technologies I mean just just
embarrassing in every way and hopefully
I mean the upside is that Steve Kings
cartoonish demand of sundar Pichai to
explain how an iphone works even though
Apple makes iPhone not Google if it
serves the purpose of bringing this
hearing out into the open so more people
realize the degree of cluelessness that
our elected officials have on these
issues I would consider that a benefit a
net gain of Steve King saying really
dumb things we need to take a break from
the Republican election fraud disaster
in North Carolina's ninth district which
we've been talking about for the last
week or so to get back to the voter
irregularities in Florida's midterm
elections which we talked about more
like a month ago without rehashing the
entire Florida situation today we
already knew about some of the strange
things that had happened in Florida this
included ballots being held up at a mail
handling facility beyond Election Day
with no real explanation as to why that
happened
The Associated Press can now report that
according to Florida officials thousands
of mailed ballots were simply never
counted because they were delivered too
late and we don't know why they were
delivered too late this is about 7,000
ballots not counted because they were
received after the deadline on Election
Day and the law in Florida is not a post
marked by law it's a mailed ballots have
to be received by 7:00 p.m. on Election
Day to be counted there's a lawsuit
claiming that they should count if
mailed before Election Day because we
can't explain why they weren't delivered
by the deadline that lawsuit is still
pending but the question is
why weren't they delivered by 7:00 p.m.
on election day given that so many of
these were held at a mail handling
facility for reasons that are as yet
unclear to us so we now have seven
thousand ballots not counted because of
this we have another four thousand mail
ballots which were set aside because
election workers who have no expertise
in handwriting analysis determined that
the signatures on the mailed ballots
didn't match comparison signatures that
were on file only six hundred and thirty
seven of those four thousand ballots
were eventually counted so we're talking
about nearly eleven thousand ballots
already without even getting into all of
the other irregularities so listen would
the results have been different in these
Florida races if these were the only
irregularities these eleven thousand
ballots and all of those ballots went
for the Democrat the answer is no okay
that's not the argument I'm making here
what I'm trying to bring out here is
that this is a meta issue where one
party the Democrats have in their
platform that we need to fix our
elections and make sure everybody who
wants to vote has their vote counted the
other party Republicans is breaking the
election system deliberately to help
themselves win by having fewer people
vote or maybe a better way to say it
would be by ensuring that fewer votes
are counted and you know Pat that when
Democrats and Republicans both are
guilty of something I call them both out
this is an issue where the Democrats
have in their platform that they want to
fix this whereas Republicans are using
these techniques to try to win election
surreptitiously
and the last place that this should be
happening is Florida because of the
chaos that transpired in 2000 you know
shortly after that we did pass the help
America Vote Act which did some good but
that's nearly 20 years old now and we
this absolutely is a meta issue and we
have to solve this for the next election
because otherwise Democrats are gonna
have a tough time winning and more
importantly the will of the people is
not going to be heard yeah I know which
side I'm on right I support doing
everything we can to ensure more people
vote and that their ballots are counted
I'm against voter purge
I don't want to reduce early voting I
don't want to reduce voting locations I
don't like sketchy ways of disqualifying
non-matching signatures I don't like
letting Russia mess with elections and
not doing a damn thing about it I know
who I support on this issue it's bad if
people don't care it's going to get
worse
climate change campaign finance reform
election systems net neutrality
rank-choice voting medicare-for-all it's
sounding like a pretty solid platform
for democrats for the next few years can
they do it can they actually capitalize
on it I wish I was more optimistic we
have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine two david p i got a
voicemail suggesting that what may be
best for the progressive movement is for
donald trump to stay in office let's
take a listen to it
hi there i'm a progressive with an
unpopular opinion in regards to the
impeachment of donald trump my personal
opinion is that we need to keep them
keep him in the oval office as long as
possible if you ever want to secure
something like medicare for all yeah
this is not as unpopular a position as
the caller seems to think i've suggested
not specifically for medicare for all i
think that Trump in the White House may
not do anything one way or the other for
Medicare for all I've been saying for a
while that what may ultimately be best
is for a scandal-ridden Trump to stay in
rather than turning the reins over to
Mike Pence either through resignation or
impeachment and that over the long term
that's what might catalyze more activism
and lead to the best outcome for the
left in 2020 oh the argument around
Medicare for all I'm not sure I fully
understand but actually I know a lot of
people who believe this so it's not a
fringe perspective and it's not an
unpopular perspective it's just more one
of their are the political implications
of impeachment or resignation and then
there's also is impeachment the right
thing is resignation the right thing and
you have to consider them both
separately but they also have to be
considered sort of an in concert with
each other on today's bonus show Piers
Morgan said
that he should be Donald Trump's new
chief of staff we're going to talk about
McDonald's taking a stand on antibiotic
use in beef production and we will also
talk about the CFO from I'm not sure how
it's pronounced is it Huawei well who
has been granted bail in Canada Huawei
and we will be talking about that and
much more on today's bonus show how do
you get access to the bonus show very
easy become a member
ww join pakman.com become a patron for
at least five bucks a month patreon.com
slash david pakman show we will speak to
you on the bonus show in just minutes
hope you're going to be there
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]